what we got going on today
well first of all
arc invest
wait mark invests
it's very hard to say kathy wood the ceo
of arkhanvest said that the u.s is
already in an economic downturn there is
no question about it i was going to say
something else
she said we think we are in a recession
we think a big problem out there is
inventories that increase of which i've
never seen this large in my career and
i've been around for 45 years meanwhile
the new york federal reserve president
john williams said that he expects the
u.s to of the u.s economy to avoid a
recession even as he sees the need for
significantly higher interest to control
inflation this is how markets get made
is that some people think we're in a
recession and going deeper into one
other people say that we're not in a
recession they don't think that we're
going to go into one okay but one is
delusional clearly because how can both
be true well are they delusional or are
they simply looking at different data
points or are they looking at the same
data points and getting different
conclusions but that's where the market
gets made is that it take take a stock
as an example you can take 10 investors
they all can look at one stock and they
can look at what the price of the stock
is they can look at all the financials
they can look at all of the public
reporting of that company et cetera and
some of them will come out and say this
is a buy it's undervalued it's going to
be amazing and other people look at it
like this is the crappiest company in
the world i wouldn't touch it with a
stick right and when you look at that
it's they're all synthesizing the data
differently and so what a lot of is
happening here is that you get people
inside of uh the economist organizations
you get the federal reserve presidents
uh you get you know people who go on
mainstream media saying hey recession's
not coming you also get folks who are
investing uh or in some of these
positions saying that a recession is
here
and what we do know if we just go with
kind of facts is that in q1 the gdp data
in the united states we contracted on an
annualized basis it was minus 1.4
and so for there to be a recession the
definition of a recession is two
consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth which means that if in q2
we get negative gdp growth then we are
technically in a recession if you go
back to march of 2020 what happened was
we got negative gdp growth uh in q1 and
we got negative gdp growth in q2 and so
it was categorized as a quote-unquote
recession but it was like the shortest
recession ever because then everything
came flying back and so the question now
is going to really just hinge on is gdp
growth in q2 positive or negative if
it's negative by definition we're in a
recession if it's positive then by
definition we're not in a recession and
so if you put a aside for a second the
quote-unquote definition of a recession
and you say what are people ultimately
getting at really what i think people
are trying to get at is just are we
headed towards better times or are we
actually headed towards worse times and
it's hard to see a world where we are
going to be headed towards better times
until the federal reserve and many of
the kind of tighter financial conditions
that we put on the market
pivot and head back towards loose
monetary policy and start to encourage
much more investment and consumption
right now they are incentivizing you not
to do that and therefore it is likely
that we are headed towards worse and
worse times questions how long will that
last how severe will it get but that's
the direction that we're headed whether
we actually get a true definition of a
recession or not i think is uh less of
importance and it's more about what is
the everyday person actually feeling on
the ground right and i think
he williams like made an important point
that there's a difference between a
recession and a slowdown correct and
right now we don't know
if we're in a slow down like we were in
2020 2021 whatever nobody knows what the
future holds yeah but what we do know is
i mean look we're at the end of june so
there's a lot of data points that people
can look at and say okay april and may
what does that look like what do we get
from the first two weeks of june so far
you basically have maybe a week or two
of data that you don't yet have access
to but other than that we have most of
the data and so that's why i said like
people are looking at the same data
points some people think we're in a
recession other people think we're not
how do you get two different conclusions
from the same data set well that's
because humans are really bad at
synthesizing information but a key piece
is we're gonna find out in the next four
order to five weeks depending on when uh
the gdp data comes out
we're going to find out exactly are we
in a recession or not because it's
either gdp grew or shrank in q2 and
that'll be the definitive answer okay
let's talk about homes and interest
rates so online real estate brokerage
redfin found that basically potential
home buyers are being able to afford
less on the same budget in the last year
and they said that they calculated that
as interest rates rise a good chunk of
home buyers have lost up to 165 000
in purchasing power on new homes in the
last year
what does that tell you
i mean this is a all-time headline for
them to come out with why
because up to could be five dollars or a
hundred and five dollars
yes uh but but that's probably less
important compared to uh
the average homeowner being able to buy
165 000
less of the home
has some to do with interest rates if
there's more and more uh kind of ex
expensive capital that's available uh
and you are dis-incentivized from
borrowing that capital to go and buy a
home
then yes you don't have as much capital
available to you to go purchase okay
but also home prices have absolutely
ripped in america and the average new
home in america now costs more than 500
000 and i think the average home in
america uh is like over 400 000 or
something so when you look at these
numbers it's like okay i don't have to
be a mathematician but if
the average real estate is going up 20
over the last year
then of course people have less ability
to buy it especially when
wages don't keep up and so there's many
different factors that go into this but
it is pretty clear that a year ago
somebody would be able to buy more of a
home uh or get more for their money than
they can today i just don't think you
can only say it's because of interest
rates interest rates is a big piece of
it but there's also things around
inflation uh there's things about wage
growth there's many factors that go into
it that uh ultimately get you to the
conclusion do you want to guess the five
cities where that have experienced the
biggest drops in affordability
miami no
new york no
l.a no
austin
yes
chicago no
i went one for five all right what are
the five cities phoenix raleigh
las vegas salt lake city and austin so
these are places phoenix i should have
known they're already kind of affordable
to live in but there was such a boom in
the last year of people buying homes
there that the
affordability i don't know how they're
calculating that if you were to look at
uh cities where prices exploded uh i'm
actually surprised that miami wouldn't
be in there uh phoenix definitely austin
as well those are uh winners of kind of
the covid uh um kind of shuffle where
people were moving to new cities uh salt
lake city also uh there are a lot of
tech companies and workers who move
there um but but the affordability thing
my guess is that they're trying to
measure not only home price increases
but also things like wage growth and
elsewhere because affordability is if
home prices go up 20 but everyone's
making 50 more money then actually it
became more affordable
right instead what happens here is uh
you have to look at both sides of the
equation i need to work on my town
raleigh north carolina by the way
becoming less affordable was that
interesting i like crowley
you're okay on raleigh do you like i
love raleigh
said with some hesitation no no okay i
genuinely do i it's the one of the only
places uh in the world in my opinion i'm
super biased for this i don't know i
grew up uh in the area um it's one of
the only places in the world where i
think that uh built into uh kind of the
city and the expectations and the social
scene and all that is there's a really
healthy uh work-life balance uh so if
that's what you're seeking
it's great place and also they've i'm
gonna call it modernized or kind of
started to redevelop a lot of the
downtown area uh they have things like
research triangle park there's a lot of
universities there's young people
there's research there's unc duke nc
state right you know whatever duke's
best but uh
listen i'm a sports fan all right what's
up i was pleasantly surprised by raleigh
um all right so you know buy now pay
later
unfortunately we do not have our 11 year
old jacob um correspondent here to tell
us that this is basically a loan
um you do not buy anything that's still
one of my favorite things he's so good
he said so it's like uh alone yeah
literally
all right but
these companies that you know like
killarna and what is it a firm that is
they kind of are faltering now because
they were very um big before
there's they're facing increased
competition with apple trying to do
something that we've talked about
previously but also companies like mandu
hakodo and billy
are raising a ton of money and now
they're the darlings of buy now pay
later but the difference is they're i
think this is brilliant they're not
going after consumers
they're going after businesses so it's
b2b not b2c and i think it makes sense
that way there's a lot to unpack here uh
we don't have time to go through at all
but what i would say is uh one clear
critique of the buy now pay laters
or a caution is most of them have not
lived through a true economic recession
and so they've been started you know
post the global financial crisis what
does this look like if all of a sudden
uh these products are available what
does it look like in terms of people
repaying um how does that change the
risk profile how do rates change there's
a bunch of questions in there uh
what is surprising to me is that people
are claiming that they're faltering uh i
would like to know why they think that
they're faltering um and it doesn't
surprise me though that somebody said
hey if this works for retail why don't
we go business to business uh it gets
back to this whole idea of um trying to
get better and better credit uh as like
the counterparty so would you rather
underwrite the credit of an individual
or would you rather write underwrite the
credit of a business most people would
say the business it's got a longer track
record it usually has more uh kind of uh
capital it's got more sophisticated
financial kind of management all that
stuff
do you want to hear something pretty
crazy real quick
there's a little alpha for everyone i'm
not going to tell you all of the details
because i'm i'm currently trying to
figure something out and i'll let you
know what's up as long as it's not beta
i want to hear alpha
uh there's a gentleman daniel ludwig
just ignore that don't don't say
anything about him but there's a
gentleman daniel ludwig who many of you
may not have ever heard of before he at
one point was the richest man in the
world and part of how he became one of
the richest men in the world is that he
figured out a very unique lending
structure so what he did was he wanted
to
go and purchase an oil tanker but he
didn't have the money to buy the oil
tanker so instead he went to a customer
and he said hey will you sign a contract
with me to move your oil around the
world they said yeah of course we will
and he said amazing and so they signed
the contract he then went to the bank
and he said hey rather than underwrite
me as the individual why don't you just
underwrite this contract and it's the
credit of the company that is going to
be paying me that ultimately you're
dependent on so bank said wow we've
never done that before but like that's
interesting we'd much rather underwrite
that big oil company than underwrite you
as an individual so they went ahead they
gave them the loan he went and bought
the oil tanker and he started to service
it but a key piece to it was that the
oil company did not pay him the
contractual payments as the oil tanker
company instead the oil company paid the
bank directly so at the end of all of
this the bank's counterparty to the loan
was actually the oil company which had
great credit and a big balance sheet
daniel ludwig was the person who figured
out how to do this and once that they
actually paid off the loan took years
but once they did that daniel ludwig
would end up actually owning the oil
tanker free and clear but he actually
wasn't the counterparty to the loan and
so eventually banks got even smarter and
they said why don't we get both of you
to be the counterparty and so they would
underwrite the oil company the oil
company would make the payments directly
to the bank but also daniel ludwig he
would have to
personally guarantee the loan as well
for the oil tankers and he went and
built this vast kind of
fleet of oil tankers around the world
simply by figuring out i don't have
great credit
as an individual um when he was starting
out and so he was able to get the banks
to take the credit of his customers
rather than him and that led to a huge
boom and now this is like a pretty
popular thing that people will do uh
when they're trying to finance certain
types of companies so that's what
ultimately by now pay later that's what
makes me think about it
you can underwrite the individuals but
you'd much rather have the credit
counter party be a large company where
you can actually underwrite it uh in a
much more kind of efficient effective
way
yeah yeah that's alpha right there ain't
nobody ever heard that story
this is what he spent the weekend doing
literally this is what i do on the
weekends i go and i learn stuff like
this all right what's uh what's next
all right wait what's next yeah okay ey
so ernst young you know the consulting
company
heard of them or the accounting from
whatever they consult too right they do
it all um
they have been slapped with a record 100
million dollar fine from the us
government after regulators discovered
that the company knew some of its
auditors were cheating on exams for
several several years and did nothing to
stop it
oh yeah that's not good on cpa ethics
exams of all things what
what was the cheating
the church wasn't like uh
like they were sharing answers taking
the test together was it
you know that's a very good question
i think that should be
wow i mean 100 million dollar fine is i
would think a large one no it doesn't
say uh
interesting that they don't say what the
cheating was um but uh that would be
definitely a piece uh
uh that would want to know and um
[Music]
it's very like mushy it says this action
involves breaches of trust by
gatekeepers within the gatekeeper
entrusted to audit many of our nation's
public companies yeah who audits the
auditor interesting question
don't trust verify that's a great point
i would like to learn more i'm going to
go do some research this afternoon and
i'll try to find sorry guys i don't have
the answer for you but i will look it up
but that is uh that's pretty crazy um
and uh
lili uh is saying the ridiculous part is
that the ethics exam is an open book
test wait how do you cheat on open book
tests all right so it says that that's a
great question they were using answer
keys and sharing them with their
colleagues
see
i don't know anything about i mean i
don't know anything about how this works
uh
my
question
would be is this something that happens
at every single one of these and
eventually the overseers or the
regulators were like all right enough
and they went after one to set an
example or is this like a uh pervasive
uh kind of bad actions inside of one of
these organizations i i don't know
anything about it uh but i don't know
but answer keys if it's an open book
test
aren't the answers in the book
um they should be but they they were
using answer keys like the actual
answers to oh like one a two b three c
uh got it right that's not good yeah
yeah i mean come on it's cheating come
on
all right what's next i wonder how they
caught them okay
um they probably found the answer keys
and they were like what's that and
somebody's like
all right let's talk about moon dust
and cockroaches
um so nasa
nasa has asked um
boston base are our auction to halt the
sale of moon dust collected during the
1969 apollo 11 mission that had
subsequently been fed to cockroaches
during an experiment to determine if the
lunar rock contained any sort of
pathogen that posed a threat to
terrestrial rewind this again what are
they doing they so they fed cockroaches
some moon dust to see if they would get
sick whether the moon dust contained you
know like toxins and what happens
unclear but nasa wants its moon dust to
pack who has it because they said it
still belongs to the federal government
this auction house
an auction house has moon dust it says
the material from the experiment
included including a vial with about 40
milligrams of moon dust and three
cockroach carcasses was expected to sell
for at least four hundred thousand
dollars but has been pulled from the
auction block because the government
wants its cockroaches and money do you
know how they got the moon dust probably
from the moon during the expedition oh
no i know but how did the auction house
get it did like an employee take it yeah
that's a very good question you have a
lot of very good questions i mean these
are just simple questions
okay well hold on a second if you write
an article and you say hey the auction
house has moon dust and cockroach
carcasses
and you don't include how the auction
house got it and then you go on to say
that the federal government wants it
back no it says that there was no uh
i think they okay so they brought it to
the university of minnesota to study
them but then they were never returned
to nasa so and it stayed there so so
then an auction house went to the
university of minnesota or did somebody
take it stop asking questions
listen
i'm just trying to ask simple questions
like how does the dust from the moon end
up at the auction house next time i will
read the article more carefully
maybe they don't have the information
there we don't know nobody knows all
right ladies and gentlemen